all the things you don't know about how
to wear a tie we get questions about
this a lot how long should my tigey we
please answer it once and for all
it's all based on where your pant sets
you're going to want to tie your tie
make sure the tip of the tie comes to
the middle of the waistband or the
middle of the belt John actually tied
this tie and himself I will give him
total credit yeah he did a perfect job
of it you don't see any of the shirt
coming around here yeah so it sort of
closes the gap yeah sure another little
GQ detail that I always see you put into
a tie I've seen it on our covers over
and over again is the dimple it is
actually forbidden to be in GQ out
example if you look at any of those old
photographs of you know silent movies
film stars into the talkies into the 50s
and the 60s the dimple was always there
and it was basically a way to really
make the tie Kris make that not really
severe or make the idea of wearing a tie
really really an important detail right
in your wardrobe so you want to tie a
classic foreign hand which is once
around and through the right when you
get to about there you want to start
forming the dimple pull the tie and
formulate it once it's in I like to grab
the side and the knot and pull is our
get a really tight knot that has a
dimple that will stay there all day
exactly you ready to go the tie lifts
it's mundane to some to us pretty much
everything - for me it's you know we're
three dimensional beings and it's like I
want to see a little bit of movement in
that tie just give it a little slack at
the top clip on the tie bar a lot of
people think the tie bar is just to
attach the two pieces of tie that's
actually - attention to
we've got the built-in lifts it's gonna
stay there because you tie bar is in
place find a cover without a lift
this is GQ and we're not gonna talk to
you about ties without showing you some
actual ties Jim what is going on back
there
bring a racket eyes everywhere I go oh
you old behind you I think if we were
standing here a year or two ago most of
these ties would be silk right believe
it or not every one of these ties are
will these are not the old wooly ties
you remember of the past not a
foxhunting tie this is not work you know
you're in Scotland business time is the
business tie I don't like sending emails
what we do now I mean you even have a
dress check here yeah you have a
houndstooth like we put on the cover you
have a little bit of a woolly or some
retro pattern and a strike run all in
one I'd say if you've got these five
ties in your arsenal or something
similar to it you're going to be set for
the season and I think what you're going
to want to do is take those silks loom
the back of the closet especially for
fall right maybe one day they'll come
back and style but this fall all about
the will it's all about things all right
thank you Jim thank you